Hi everyone, in this lesson, we're going to go and take a look at another way to make
layered materials.
And we're going to be doing so using the motion design tools.
Now this is not a deep dive, but a simple overview of what you can do and the potential
they have.
We do have classes that go into this in more depth.
So let's go and jump right in.
One of the first things you want to do is turn on the motion design plugin in your
workspace with Unreal.
Once you have that on, you'll be able to have full range and to be able to work with different
aspects of motion design in your scene.
Let's go and jump into Unreal.
And I'll show you some of the tools we have at our fingertips with this active.
In our scene, you'll see that I have a simplified material setup.
This is a motion design material.
If I click on this, we'll be able to see this material in place.
And we can go and double click on it to have it come up into our scene.
And you'll see we now have the motion design interface here, as I should say for the material.
Now there's several ways to make a new material.
One of them, you can simply make a new cube, and the material will be active.
You can also go in here and open and generate a material, you can even export it, save
it and a few other advanced settings in here, particularly catering more towards broadcast.
So let's go ahead and open and generate a generated material, if you wish.
And it will show you the network that it works just like a regular material, but it
runs the process for you.
And oh, I know what you're thinking.
That is a noodle fest.
And yes, it is.
But the nice thing about working with this type of material system is it actually does
all the network connections for you.
You don't have to do a lot of heavy lifting, which is really beneficial.
Now if you ever want to clean these up, you're more than welcome to, you might want to use
some named redirect nodes, which we go over in our foundational courses.
But for the most part, again, it's quick, fast and easy to use.
And you don't have to have a lot of the overhead workflows that you had before.
Let me show you what I mean.
For time's sake, let's go and just make a cube for now.
So I'm going to go in here and go to modeling.
And I'll simply just make a cube.
So now I have a cube in my scene, let's place them right here.
And I'm going to hit accept.
This cube now has a new material.
And we can set this up the way that we want.
We can do a material instance on the offset, right on the outset, if we want to.
I'm going to keep it as a PBR.
And again, you can choose opaque, emissive, translucent, or you just want everything.
I'm going to do PBR for now.
And I'm going to hit Continue.
This continue now gives me a base to work with.
Now there is one thing I do want to point out when working with motion design.
There are two ways to get where you need to go.
One of them, you can go to motion design here.
And these are for the foundational pieces that you may need for motion, and for movement
and for three dimensional pieces.
But there's also a button up here, which kind of takes you where we're at now.
We simply went in here and opened up a material, which kind of skipped any camera information
that would come up.
Because when you click on this particular one, camera and animation pieces may come
up that you may not need.
So sometimes if you just have it set in place already, you can avoid that step without
having more things on your interface that you necessarily don't need.
That's kind of what I did with this one.
But initially, if it happens, don't worry about it.
Next time you open up on real, you can simply just open a material that you've already started.
Because the camera will work a little bit differently.
Because it's based for broadcast, I just want to make that note real quick.
So notice we have our scene in here, and we have our texture set up, we can open
up our offset or global tiling, and all these different informations that we need
in here, we can look at our channels, and we can look at our base color.
Now the base color is where we're going to be doing most of the heavy lifting when
it comes to layering.
What I can do in here if I want to, is to go into each one of these and change how
it's digested for our filtering or layering, I should say, and it works just like Photoshop,
you'll see an overlay, soft overlay all the way down to color and hue, saturation,
luminosity, and if you have some sort of layer system already set up, you can add
that it's actually pretty nice and easy to use.
You'll notice there's also a keyframe if you need to animate them, but we're not
going to go into that in this particular case.
So I'm going to right click in here, and if I wanted to, I can insert a layer above.
Let's go and do that.
Now I have a layer above this one, but I'm going to choose a texture to be different.
At any time, you can choose an added texture in your scene and change it.
In this case, if I wanted to, I can go and do a radial gradient.
It's going to generate that for me and update that.
And now I have a radial gradient.
But maybe I want to filter this one down below, and I want to change his texture also.
So I can go into the details that are down below, and I can choose something like a wind
noise, kind of the one that I already have in place.
But that wind noise, I want to be able to filter through that gradient.
So I can choose overlay in this particular case, it will update and generate and give
me that piece and look that I want.
And there you go, you can see that we're filtering through.
And we can choose that for any number of layers that we decided to create, say, Hey,
I want to insert another one, or another one, I want to duplicate it, I want to change
it, I want to toggle layers, you can actually do whatever you want in this particular case.
But it gives you a quick way to make these materials and get them into place in
your scene.
And then you can choose how they are going to be used in a particular scenario, depending
what you want.
And to be able to have that Photoshop type of output, notice he's multiply here, you
can see more of the gradient, it can be pretty helpful to be able to get up and running and
spun up the way that you need for a layered material.
Awesome.
So hopefully you found that interesting, and it can benefit you in your progress and what
you want to do when it comes to exploring layered materials.
In the next video, we're going to take a look at NPCs and how they work and how
to use them in Unreal.
Thanks again.